before the 1970s people looking for jobs
in the u.s would
open up the help wanted section of their
newspapers and see this
one set of opportunities for women and
one for men
we don't see job ads like this anymore
largely because it's been illegal for
decades
but also because advertising is now much
more targeted
instead of one classifieds page we have
our social feeds
each crafted by algorithms for an
audience of one
so when this ad went out on facebook and
reached a group of people that was 91
men those outside that audience probably
didn't know it existed
and the same goes for this ad which
facebook displayed for an audience that
was 88
women that disparity wasn't because the
advertiser told facebook to target users
by gender
i know that because this is the
advertiser yeah so my name is muhammad
ali i go by ali
he's part of a research group at
northeastern university that has spent
thousands of dollars buying ads to try
to figure out who facebook will show
them to
and why
[Music]
if an ad shows up on your facebook or
instagram feed there are two parties
that decided you should see it
first the advertiser included you in
their target audience either by
uploading a list of specific email
addresses phone numbers or previous
visitors to their website
or by choosing from thousands of
attributes that facebook offers like
californians under 40 who like
basketball
second facebook decided who in that pool
would actually see the ad
through an automated calculation based
in part on what they know
about you it's that second step that ali
and his colleagues wanted to study if
they uploaded a list of randomly
generated american phone numbers and
then turned off all the targeting except
adults in the us
who would facebook deliver the ad to
so you set up a bodybuilding ad and a
cosmetic ad
and said we don't want to target this
any further than
the exact like random phone numbers that
we put in
right and then what were your results
when facebook started telling you
who was actually seeing this ad what did
they what did they tell you
so so yeah immediately like we sort of
expected that the bodybuilding ad was
more relevant to men and that's exactly
we saw like somewhere close to 80 to 85
percent of the audience was just men
and the link that we advertised to l.com
about the makeup kits that you could buy
uh that went primarily they were able to
collect the results of the ads as they
ran
so they knew the gender sku was there
early on suggesting that it wasn't
introduced by user behavior
their experiment showed that facebook
automatically analyzes the content of an
ad to compare it to a user's interest
and how do they know what a user cares
about well they have data from your
profile and everything you and your
friends have ever done on facebook and
instagram
as well as websites you've visited
things you've purchased apps you've
installed your location your devices
and more all this information fuels
automated predictions about whether you
are likely to engage with any given ad
and that prediction influences whether
the ad shows up on your feed
at all you can get a sense of what
facebook thinks you're interested in by
visiting your ad preferences page
or your ad interests on instagram you
might notice how some of these interests
could correlate with your gender your
age
your income level or your race
and then you wanted to look at race but
it sounds like facebook does not give
you data on the race of people that are
seeing an ad so how do you study that
yeah that was one of the hardest things
to do uh we thought we could
use a different custom audience instead
of random phone numbers we could take
voter records from north carolina which
are public
and they have the race of the person
listed as well
then they bought ads for rolling stone
articles that were either about country
albums
hip-hop albums or general top 30 albums
and targeted an equal number of white
and black users
and it was like surprising how much the
skew to the black users was for the
hip-hop ad versus the
countries and and the top 30 the generic
ad was just
50-50. facebook's algorithms are trained
to not show people ads they won't be
interested in
but there may be cases where we're not
comfortable with facebook making those
predictions
one study by ali and his colleagues
investigated how this plays out with
political ads
and found that despite targeting the
same audiences using the same goal
bidding strategy and budget
an ad pointing to bernie sanders site
went to mostly democrats
and an ad for donald trump went to
mostly republicans
it cost one and a half times more for an
ad linking to sanders site
to reach the same number of
conservatives as a trump ad because
facebook subsidizes what they consider
to be relevant
ads and then we move on to
housing and employment ads and these are
considered sort of a different
category why is that
because these are sort of legally
protected for example the housing ads
are protected in the fair housing act
an advertiser cannot discriminate in
those cases so at that point you're
excluding someone from a life
opportunity
which becomes much more problematic
because it's actually a legal violation
that's at stake
possibly awesome facebook allows
advertisers to exclude
certain ethnic groups from seeing an ad
dozens of employers are placing job ads
on facebook
that discriminate against older workers
facebook is revamping its targeted
advertisements after
settling lawsuits with civil rights
groups
in response to media reports and several
lawsuits facebook has been removing some
of the targeting
attributes that an advertiser could use
to discriminate against
demographic groups and they're paying
special attention to ads related to
employment
housing and credit but the role that the
ad delivery system plays
remains unsolved when ali and his team
tested out ads for job openings in
different industries without targeting
any demographic groups facebook
generated some skewed audiences
remember the lumber industry post went
to mostly men and the cleaner post went
to mostly women
taxi driver as we dan uh basically
70 of the audience was black users
these results don't mean that facebook
is directly basing their predictions on
our gender or race
instead it looks for patterns in all of
our data maybe people who shop at a
men's clothing site
and who like joe rogan are less likely
to click on an ad for a job teaching
preschool
maybe your data is similar to theirs in
some way and so they predict that you
also won't click on that ad instead they
show it to someone who likes
skin care and feminism and if that
person clicks the system gets a new data
point affirming that prediction
a complaint filed by the u.s department
of housing and urban development states
that this process
inevitably recreates groupings defined
by users protected class
they said that facebook's ad delivery
system prevents advertisers who want to
reach a broad audience of users from
doing so
according to a report by propublica a
construction workers union wanted to
recruit diverse candidates for its
apprenticeship program
so they made ads featuring women but
found that facebook still showed them to
mostly men
apply to join the local 150
apprenticeship program to level up your
career
and wouldn't any ad targeting system
with
sort of sufficiently rich data about
people have this kind of effect
we believe so uh because a lot of these
things for example custom audiences or
all of these targeting features their
industry practice they
they're also in google's or linkedin's
or twitter's advertising platform
so the general ethos of how these
systems work is the same
it's a question that the industry as a
whole hasn't answered
when exactly is it unacceptable for an
algorithm to decide that relevant
audiences
are segregated once
you